[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver pour
la saison 2 de sens public grâce à vous
l'émission a remporté un vrai succès
d'audience la saison dernière merci donc
de votre fidélité on va conserver la
même exigence éditoriale continuée de
donner du sens à l'actualité se mettre
au service des citoyens vous proposer
des clés de compréhension des mutations
profondes de notre société et cette
saison comme l'an dernier je vous donne
rendez-vous tous les jours du lundi au
jeudi en début de saison c'est bien de
redonner les dates et les horaires donc
c'est du lundi au jeudi c'est à 18h en
direct c'est à 22h en rediffusion 90
minutes qui seront découpés en deux
grands débats un débat d'actu et un
autre volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour débat de société
plus prospectif et justement c'est à la
fin du mois que le gouvernement doit
présenter son plan de sobriété
énergétique mais la première ministre et
le président de la République
occupe déjà le terrain Emmanuel Macron
tenait une conférence de presse tout à
l'heure pour annoncer même s'il n'a pas
employé ce terme une éventuelle taxe
européenne sur les super profits faut
dire qu'avec un mégawatt-heure qui a
dépassé les 1000 euros fin août et un
parc nucléaire qui tourne à 40 % de ses
capacités la France va devoir résoudre
une équation très compliquée quelle
marge de manœuvre réponse dans trois
quarts d'heure mais d'abord l'actualité
politique et notamment la campagne pour
l'élection du nouveau président du parti
les républiques
Bruno Retailleau sans doute Aurélien
Pradier le match s'est lancé ce week-end
à Angers Audrey était sur place au
campus des jeunes LR
porté par les encouragements de quelques
jeunes Bruno Retailleau le patron des
sénateurs LR entre deux plein pied dans
la bataille pour la présidence du parti
sa stratégie est simple rassembler et
relever une droite qui a selon lui trop
déçu les Français à condition c'est
qu'après tant d'échec au présidentiel on
peut relever le gant il y a pas de
fatalité ma condition et à une seule
condition c'est qu'on ne se contente pas
de ripoliner la façade et qu'on change
tout du sol au plafond face à lui le
député des Alpes-Maritimes Eric Ciotti
un ami avec qui il partage de très
nombreuses idées chacun essaye donc de
marquer sa différence sur le régalien on
est à peu près tous d'accord c'est sur
l'économie qu'aujourd'hui qu'il faut
définir une ligne voilà et là on a du
travail à faire et moi j'ai des lignes
elles sont claires avec une baisse
massive des impôts quelle ligne choisir
quel chef pour l'incarner les cadres et
les militants sont divisés certains
restent fidèles aux députés sudistes
c'est un homme qui est loyal qui n'a
jamais trahi qui a été fidèle à sa
famille politique ce sont des valeurs
importantes que doit incarner un
président un candidat en tout cas à la
présidence de notre famille politique
d'autres comme le sénateur Stéphane Le
rues dulier ancien soutien d'érections
l'unité le rassemblement devront être
les maîtres mots et donc je pense
humblement que Bruno Retailleau par son
expérience de président de groupe peut
relever ce défi qui s'offre à nous pour
les années à venir des divisions qui
pourraient profiter à un troisième homme
Aurélien Pradier qui se revendiquent
d'une droite plus sociale même s'il ne
sait toujours pas déclaré ce que je peux
simplement vous dire c'est que il faut
toujours se méfier des troisième homme
ou des 3e femme dans notre famille
politique comme dans toutes les autres
élections en général c'est vers celui
qui n'est pas attendu que les surprises
arrivent les ténor du parti ont encore
trois mois pour faire la différence mais
cette compétition interne dans une
famille politique divisée laisse
craindre une nouvelle guerre des chefs à
droite et pour ce premier débat de cette
nouvelle saison de sens public je suis
très heureux d'accueillir Émilie
zappalski bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
communicantes fondatrice de l'agence
Émilie conseil Jean-Daniel Lévy bonjour
et bienvenue directeur délégué d'Harry
interactive Jean Gary l'historien
président du comité Histoire
parlementaire bienvenue Jean heureux de
vous retrouver et Mathieu croissanto
très heureux de retrouver Mathieu
également éditorialiste politique
présent tous les lundis et les mercredis
dans l'émission Les mardis et les jeudis
c'est Laetitia cruppa qui est à votre
place alors on commence donc cette
bataille pour la présidence des
républicains qui va animer l'actualité
politique pendant les trois prochains
mois puisque le premier tour de
se tiendra les trois et quatre décembre
Emily s'appelle je démarre sur la
candidature de Bruno retaillewesk est-ce
qu'elle change profondément la donne
pour vous bah les deux érections et
Bruno retailleux sont à peu près sur la
même ligne sur le côté régalien alors on
voit un Bruno Retailleau qui se veut
plus rassembleur un peu plus calme on va
dire mais je dirais que Éric Ciotti
l'avait réussi son coup pendant la
primaire des républicains parce qu'il
était sorti du lot il s'était révélé
finalement et quelque part c'est sa
ligne qui a été suivie un petit peu
maladroitement par Valérie Pécresse mais
il a imprimé quand même beaucoup à la
fois sur sa personnalité et aussi sur sa
ligne parce qu'il sort en tête du
premier tour au Congrès ensuite il
perdent s'il a moins de soutien mais il
sort en tête et puis quelque part
c'était là outsider c'est celui qu'on
avait pas vu venir qui a eu beaucoup de
personnalités une façon de faire un
style même avec son accent il y avait
quelque chose qui marquait vraiment les
esprits donc je pense qu'en termes de
popularité et de sortir un petit peu du
lot il a le devant après ils sont sur la
même ligne donc est-ce que ça peut
changer vraiment c'est vrai que le
troisième homme aurait bien Pradier
plutôt gaulis social un peu plus
macrocompatible d'ailleurs on pourrait
dire va changer la donne on pense tout
de suite à la si on se projette un petit
peu plus loin c'est l'après Macron c'est
le post Macron qui va être intéressant
parce que des candidatures comme
Aurélien Pradier pour des gens déçus par
Macron avec une France qu'on dit
beaucoup à droite même si moi je suis un
petit peu sceptique sur cette analyse on
comprendrait qui pourrait récupérer un
petit peu les cendres d'un macronisme un
peu en tout cas des macronistes un peu
déçus si moi seulement de second mandat
mais tout le monde fait les mêmes
analyses ce projet déjà dans l'après
Macron on fera aussi cette analyse dans
la seconde partie de ce débat parce
qu'on va parler du du Parti socialiste
après la tribune que Bernard Cazeneuve a
publié dans Le le Journal du Dimanche
Jean-Daniel Lévy est-ce que si on parle
de popularité tient justement c'est pas
faire un jeu à Bruno Retailleau de dire
qu'il est peut-être un peu moins
identifié connu du grand public
erikiotti alors un c'est pas faire un
jure et en plus c'est vrai voilà pour
une fois je dis quelque chose de juste
ça commence bien cette saison et dans le
cas des enquêtes qu'on peut être amené à
réaliser on a en gros 80% des Français
qui déclarent qu'ils sont carrés de
pouvoir me parler d'eriki en tout cas
d'avoir un avis ça tombe à 65 %
lorsqu'on parle de Bruno Retailleau ça
c'est le premier aspect puis le deuxième
aspect quand on entre dans le détail et
notamment auprès de la population qui va
le plus nous intéresser c'est-à-dire les
sympathisants pas les électeurs mais les
sympathisants républicains il y a et une
notoriété qui est plus importante en
faveur d'érections notamment parce que
il a déjà passé en fait l'étape du
congrès de la fois précédente avec
également un rôle de la télévision qui a
été fondamental et donc dans ce contexte
là une croissance de l'exposition la
notoriété qui a été extrêmement
importante donc il y a qui profite chez
les proches des républicains en faveur
d'Éric Ciotti et qui même en termes de
questions de confiance qui est la
question que nous posons de manière
régulière un avantage également en
faveur d'Éric Ciot par rapport à Bruno
Retailleau pour faire vite sur 100
proches des républicains vous en avez
51% qui déclarent accorder leur
confiance à Éric Ciotti et un tiers à
peu près qui déclare accorder leur
confiance à Bruno retaillod et peut-être
rappelé que ça sera quand même un
congrès donc c'est à dire fermer auprès
des militants et pas auprès sur les
cartes à jour quoi comme ça prenne un
public qui va être un public restreint
ou là si je me trompe pas il y a un peu
plus de 50 000 personnes et qui sont en
fait concernés en tout cas aujourd'hui
et puis effectivement comme vous l'avez
indiqué il va y avoir des mobilisations
de cartes c'est-à-dire en fait faire en
sorte que dans les fédérations et puis
ça va le plus de personnes qui sont
inscrites avec l'hypothèse qu'elle soit
amenée à voter pour les personnes qui
les ont fait s'inscrire tout à l'heure
il y a une analyse régionale qui va être
faite forcément dans les dernières
semaines qui précéderont le premier tour
Jean garrigue si on si on prend un peu
la personnalité là de alors on est sur
les deux pour l'instant favori
évidemment on va pas jouer jouer
l'élection avant qu'elle qu'elle soit
réalisée on dirait un mot de rien
Pradier on va parler de Serge gouar qui
est l'aire d'Orléans qui est
officiellement candidat lui aussi on
n'oublie pas mais si on parle de ce de
ce duel qui s'annonce en très lexioti et
Bruno retaillod en terme de personnalité
peut-être d'héritage politique qui sont
assez proches comment vous les situez en
tout cas sur le régalien ils sont assez
proches faut d'ailleurs rappeler au fond
que ce sont deux candidats par défaut
parce que celui qui avait vocation à
prendre le parti Laurent Wauquiez s'en
est abstenu c'est quand même une donnée
importante parce que le candidat
potentiel pour la présidentielle de 2027
c'est Laurent Wauquiez a priori ce que
tout peut arriver en politique et donc
de la relation qui existera entre soit
erikioti soit Bruno retaillod soit
Aurélien Pradier et Laurent Wauquiez
découleront beaucoup de choses pour pour
cette famille quand Bruno retaillod
parle de ripolinet il doit ripoliner une
famille qui est avec une lézarde majeure
au cœur de cette famille on l'a vu au
moment de la campagne de de Valérie
Pécresse qui était une campagne je
dirais comme on disait dual presque
presque écartelé entre entre deux lignes
là c'est pas le cas ils ont à peu près
le même ADN sur le plan régalien
le l'avantage me semble-t-il mais
d'ailleurs ça a été évoqué dans le
reportage de Bruno Retailleau c'est
quand même d'être depuis longtemps le
patron des sénateurs républicains or le
Sénat aujourd'hui c'est quand même le
bastion et c'est là où ils sont
majoritaires et c'est quelque chose qui
à l'intérieur de sa famille politique la
crédibiliser mais en même temps ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure sur le plan de la
comment dire d'une forme de charisme en
tout cas de de popularité c'est c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt érikiotique qui
aurait l'avantage mais je le répète à
droite dans la tradition de la famille
politique il faut avoir une personnalité
charismatique c'est sûr et sinon il y a
pas rien n'est possible mais il faut
aussi quand même ménager des
sensibilités on voit kervé Morin par
exemple les les centristes sans tristes
de droite on dit d'emblée non pas pas de
pas d'accord si c'est petit donc ça
aussi c'est des donc risque de risque
effectivement que la lézarde dont vous
parlez s'agrandissent encore un peu plus
Matthieu moi ce qui me frappe c'est que
c'est quand même une bataille de second
couteau
on parle du on parle des républicains on
parle du parti qui a Gérard France
pendant 10 ans sur les dernières de
décennies on parle voilà de qui a donné
Jacques Chirac qui a donné Nicolas
Sarkozy enfin voilà il y a par ministre
en amande ils ont jamais été ministre
Éric Ciotti était un outsider et un an
depuis il s'est forgé tout à fait
journal il est passé dans les politiques
à droite qui peuvent prétendre d'être
des politiques de premier plan mais
c'était pas le cas il y a encore un an
donc c'est tout frais c'était un second
couteau un patron de fédération
importante il faut d'ailleurs le
signaler il est le patron de la fin ça
fait des Alpes-Maritimes qui est une des
plus grosses fédé des républicains donc
ça explique aussi le le succès au
Congrès mais mais Bruno Retailleau
c'était quelqu'un qui était dans l'ombre
de François Fillon il y a d'ailleurs
quelque chose d'intéressant je me disais
des seconds couteaux parce qu'il ne
prétend pas aujourd'hui en tout cas
jouer les premiers rôles c'est à dire
que Hélin et l'autre sont des proches de
Laurent Wauquiez qui lui ne cache pas
ses ambitions pour pour 2020 donc on
joue la présidente d'un parti d'habitude
quand on prend un parti c'est qu'on veut
le pouvoir enfin classiquement c'est ce
qui s'est passé avec moi à gauche
c'est déjà ce qui s'est passé quand
Christian Jacob est devenu le président
de c'était l'idée de ne pas avoir un
présidentiable et de le faire sortir du
bois plus tard ça leur à Paris il faut
ensuite qu'il tire les leçons des
présidentielles parce que Bruno
retaillod dit tout doit changer d'une
seule au plafond alors généralement on
ajoute et on va ouvrir les portes et les
fenêtres enfin il y a toujours une
rhétorique comme ça de la refondation
ripoliner que Emmanuel Macron avait
employé dans le débat d'entre deux tours
mais pourquoi faire est-ce que c'est
pour continuer à dire en 2012 on aurait
dû gagner mais on a perdu en 2017 on
aurait dû gagner mais on a perdu les
Français sont d'accord avec nous en 2022
on aurait dû gagner on a perdu on ne
change pas le programme qui est bon
recycler des vieilles idées Sarkozy si
c'est ça les républicains passeront à
côté de l'essentiel l'essentiel quand on
dit refondation c'est changer non
seulement le casting les hommes pardon
mais aussi les idées le programme et la
stratégie c'est-à-dire quelles alliances
et alors là est-ce que faut plutôt
s'allier de temps en temps avec les
macronistes ou de temps en temps avec
reconquête ou et pourquoi pas avec le RN
cioti avait dit que il était plus proche
de l'urine que des manuel Macron en
souvenir voilà c'est ça c'est ce sont
des débats qui va falloir trancher mais
c'est donc pas juste une affaire de
casting que vous portez ils ont une
première phase c'est de se rassembler de
savoir quelle ligne et vous avez dit les
seconds couteaux mais non seulement ils
sont ça mais ils sont second couteau
aussi sur les thématiques le régalien
c'est pas la priorité à l'heure actuelle
on est plus sur l'inflation d'énergie et
l'écologie ils sont complètement absents
de cette thématique sauf le nucléaire
ils ont absolument rien travaillé sur
ces idées là et ils ont rien de
différencier en vous dites en effet soit
ils sont un petit peu proches du RN sur
la sécurité l'immigration soit ils sont
un peu proches de Macron mais ils ont
pas de ligne il y a pas de et ça ça va
être important moi je trouve que ce qui
est intéressant justement dans le côté
présidentiable après c'est Éric ciotique
a tout de suite sorti le ces cartes en
disant moi de toute façon je soutiens
Laurent Wauquiez donc quelque part il
arrive pour être président du parti mais
il a déjà dit qu'elle était son choix
Laurent Wauquiez il fait son chemin
quand même en tant que président de la
Région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes il a fait un
fond régional souverain il fait ses
petites expérimentations comme si
c'était comme si la région servait un
petit peu de marche-pied pour faire
quelque chose de plus national il le
fait de manière très indépendante par
rapport même aux autres présidents de ou
président de Région de droite il fait
son chemin il dit à l'état moi je n'ai
pas envie de travailler avec vous sur la
formation sur ce fond pareil un
souverain il est il dit je fais ce que
je veux il fait son chemin il se met un
peu la stratégie de Valérie Pécresse et
de Xavier Bertrand de s'appuyer sur leur
bilan de fil en région ça
cette personnalité moi j'ai des doutes
aussi en termes de communication et de
personnalité charismatique Laurent
Wauquiez bon il fait son effort il croit
un petit peu sur sa région moi j'ai
quand même un petit peu de je suis un
peu sceptique mais en tout cas l'idée de
cioti de dire moi je suis là pour être
le marche-pied d'un candidat c'est pas
idiot non plus il donne sa couleur tout
de suite et il projette pour son après
c'est normal on peut pas s'en empêcher
on se projette tous déjà dans la
prochaine présidentielle vous rendez
compte mais il y a d'abord quand même
l'enjeu de comment se positionner face
aux mains tendues de l'exécutif c'est
assez intéressant alors on va on va
quand même parler aussi des autres
candidats ou quasi-candidat il y a
d'abord Serge groart donc le maire
d'Orléans qui lui est officiellement
candidat il prône un accord de
gouvernement avec la majorité macroniste
ça c'est ultra minoritaire Jean-Daniel
Lévy aujourd'hui au sein de cette
famille politique pas forcément d'un
point de vue d'opinion mais a priori
d'un point de vue militante oui d'un
point de vue d'opinion quand vous
interrogez en fait la manière de se
positionner en fait chacune chacun des
groupes politiques les personnes qui là
être proche des réplicats sur les plus
enclins à considérer que il doit y avoir
des accords et en tout cas pas
d'opposition systématique de la part de
leur députés quand vous interrogez les
électeurs qui ont voté pour un candidat
de la nuque un candidat du RN par
exemple globalement là ils sont beaucoup
plus sur l'opposition systématique à
l'égard de cette effectué de la part du
président applique ou de la part de la
majorité présidentielle pour autant
quand on analyse et si on analyse en
fait ce qu'on a sous les yeux c'est à
dire le dernier congrès interne des
républicains la ligne est une ligne
beaucoup plus dure entre guillemets
c'est-à-dire beaucoup plus d'opposition
mais c'est pas illogique c'est-à-dire
que il faut quand même aujourd'hui être
militant répliquant et se dire ce que
c'est à dire que c'est une personne qui
déclare envers et contre tout alors même
que ils ont ils n'ont pas été qualifiés
pour le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle en 2017 ce qui a pu
apparaître comme étant un accident alors
qu'ils n'ont pas été qualifiés pour le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et là de manière
extrêmement magistrale en 2022 que on se
déclare aujourd'hui proche des répliques
donc quand on est proche des répliques
un qu'on paye une cotisation et qu'on
est militants en aucune manière à mon
avis on estime qu'il faut être un
marche-pied ou en soutien à l'égard du
président de la République sur la
question d'autorité sur la question la
sécurité sur la question la liberté sur
la question du rapport au travail pour
prendre 4 thématique il y a clairement
une césure entre cette frange de
population là et ce que peut penser le
reste de la population d'ailleurs moi ce
qui m'a frappé ce week-end lors du
campus déjeuner enfin il y a beaucoup de
ces jeunes militants qui ont jamais
connu elle est au pouvoir parce que ça
fait 10 ans qu'ils sont pas au pouvoir
donc c'est très bien moi je suis
toujours admiratif de la passion
politique mais Jean Gary c'est quand
même une dimension qu'il faut pas
oublier est-ce que ça ça peut servir à
Aurélien Pradier qui est entre
guillemets le le troisième homme plus
jeune qui c'est quelque chose qui va
s'abîmer dans le combat des chefs en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il dit c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut pas négliger
moi j'ai suffisamment travaillé sur
l'image de l'homme providentiel pour
dire qu'au fond
les tentations du Sauveur c'est le titre
d'expolis c'est toujours construite
comme ça sur le charisme d'un leader
donc ça a été le général de Gaulle ça a
été Chirac ça a été Nicolas Sarkozy qui
avait pris le parti parce qu'il y avait
ce charisme du leader se rassembleur
parce que pour le reste si on se parle
franchement qu'est-ce qu'au jour de vie
alors actuel les républicains ont
apporté de 9 ou d'original politique le
travail programmatique a pas
suffisamment été fait comme on l'a dit
c'était un proche de François Fillon on
peut imaginer que son programme il a
beau dire qu'il va ripolini ça va être
très proche de ce que nous proposait
François Fillon avant le Pénélope gate
donc franchement aujourd'hui pour peu
que du côté de la macronie on fasse
émergé au centre droit candidat du style
de d'Edouard Philippe qui est un peu de
charisme et qui soit capable de rameuter
une partie des troupes et qui sur le
plan de du programme économique et
social soit pas très très loin de ce
qu'on pourrait provoquer
pardon les républicains sur sur la
droite sur le plan du régalien de
l'identité de l'immigration vous avez
quand même il y a un terrain qui est
occupé Rick Zemmour veut rester dans le
jeu politique on se demande où est
l'espace politique on se demande où est
précisément cette capacité à émerger 6
semaines 6 semaines sauf si le
macronisme ne survit pas Emmanuel Macron
si le macronisme s'effondre et à mon
sens s'il est vraisemblable que il se
disloque mais là il y aura il y aura
quelqu'un qui va émerger à droite
d'Emmanuel Macron alors je vais vous
redonner la parole Émilie mais je
voudrais qu'on entend de Annie genvar
qu'elle a la présidente du parti LR
aujourd'hui qui dit je vais jouer un
rôle d'arbitre elle veut une compétition
mais pas la guerre
quand on préside il faut pouvoir être un
peu au dessus de la mêlée et
pour l'instant mon rôle est d'arbitré
cette compétition car c'est une
compétition évidemment mais ça ne doit
pas être une guerre donc moi je suis un
peu la garante de l'unité est-ce qu'il y
a un risque quand même Émilie parce que
quand il y a une compétition comme
celle-là surtout avec la tradition de la
de la droite dont on parlait c'est que
les fêlures nous que vous évoquiez
s'élargissent que que la bataille rangée
et puis Jean le disais l'historique de
ce parti c'était plutôt l'émergence
naturelle quelque part d'un homme
providentiel et c'est pas du tout
l'histoire a montré que quand il y avait
des guerres de chef c'était très
compliqué quand on recontait les votes
c'était encore plus compliqué ça sombrer
encore plus ça faisait sombrer encore
plus le parti moi ce que je pense en
effet je pense qu'ils peuvent jouer la
montre en fait mais ça va être le
positionnement pendant le quinquennat de
Macron et délicat mais l'idée c'est de
savoir comment se positionner pour jouer
la course de fond s'il y a des déçus de
ma ils le font un petit peu quelque part
avec cette assemblée nouvelle
configuration c'est eux qui ont fait
voter par exemple les 30 centimes à la
pompe alors que le gouvernement voulait
quelque chose de plus ciblé donc ils
essaient de jouer cette équilibre
délicat entre
pactiser un petit peu avec avec la
majorité relative mais en apportant
leurs idées tout en essayant de montrer
leurs différences mais encore une fois
moi je le rappelle je pense qu'ils ont
pas assez d'idées ça marrant parce que
je me souviens qu'il y a quelques années
les jeunes de LR disaient il nous faut
des nouvelles idées et ben ils en ont
pas des nouvelles idées ils ont aucune
ligne nouvelle le régalien ne suffit
plus
pourtant moi je pense qu'il pourrait
avoir une place on le dit cette France
qui est à droite elle cherche pas
forcément toujours Éric Zemmour bon il
faut quand même un petit peu le remettre
aux oubliettes même si réapparaît mais
le rassemblement national Marine Le Pen
a réussi à se désaboliser ce normaliser
mais il y a des gens qui iront toujours
pas voté pour elle donc il y a quand
même une place à se faire s'ils arrivent
à se rassembler ou lequel des deux en
très Richie et Bruno Retailleau peu
faire ça
avoir et puis moi ça sera d'ailleurs le
thème de notre second débat dans une
trentaine de minutes on va parler de la
politique énergétique du du gouvernement
mais je voudrais vous entendre j'en ai
Levi sur les thématiques de cette
rentrée politique et de cette rentrée
gouvernementale qui pourrait servir à
l'air vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est celle qui les portes qui
pourraient leur offrir l'occasion et en
tout cas l'occasion assez candidat qui
se présente pour devenir président du
parti de ce différencier de marquer un
territoire de être à la fois une voix
médiane entre le parti au pouvoir
d'Emmanuel Macron et le RN de l'autre
côté dans le cadre d'une étude qu'on a
une grosse étude qu'on vient de réaliser
pour le magazine challenge en fait on
avait identifié qu'il y avait trois
principales en fait mesures qui étaient
attendues de la part des Français en
tout cas trois sujets principaux le
sujet de l'écologie de l'environnement
c'est pas là-dessus sur laquelle LR est
amené à se distinguer le sujet du
pouvoir d'achat qui a très profondément
progressé on a vu que c'est là dessus en
fait qu'ils avaient pris position même
si entre les députés les sénateurs ce
n'est pas exactement la même ligne
politique était suivie notamment sur le
rapport à l'essence faut-il ou pas
bloquer le prix d'essence à 1,50 € et
puis la troisième question qui était la
question de l'avenir de la jeunesse ce
sur quoi peut-être LR peut être
également un peu plus entendu parce
qu'en fait il y a également une
dimension de perspective en fait
aujourd'hui qui n'est pas tout à fait
entendu de la part des Français
lorsqu'on les interroge sur ce que peut
être les ce qui peut être les
perspectives d'Emmanuel Macron et le
projet politique qui peut être porté de
la part d'Emmanuel Macron si on est sur
un regard qui va être un regard un peu
plus ciblé c'est-à-dire pas l'ensemble
des Français mais les électeurs qui
situent à droite sur l'échiquier
politique on va ajouter notamment la
thématique de la sécurité et de
l'immigration qui sont d'ailleurs de
plus en plus liées auprès de cette
frange de population alors que avant
quand vous interrogez des proches des
réplicans et déclarer plus avec beaucoup
plus de sécurité et beaucoup moins
d'immigration qu'ils ne le font à
l'heure actuelle et ce sont des points
qui n'ont pas réussi à être palier de la
part de Gérald Darmanin quand bien même
celui-ci vient de cette partie de la
droite donc il y a aujourd'hui
clairement sur la question de la
sécurité un point sur lesquels il y a
une attente de la part du cœur de cette
électorat là en disant il faut faire en
sorte qu'on soit amené à mieux vivre à
avoir moins peur et à faire en sorte
qu'on puisse plus se projeter
collectivement vers l'avenir il
s'adresse en plus à un électorat qui est
un électorat en moyenne même si ça s'est
pas vu la dernière élection
présidentielle plus âgée que la moyenne
des Français et dont on sait qu'ils sont
plus sensibles que les autres à cette
thématiques de la sécurité alors l'autre
actualité politique de ce weekend c'est
ce manifeste pour une autre gauche
lancée par l'ancien Premier ministre de
François Hollande Bernard Cazeneuve
texte publié dans le Journal du Dimanche
signé par 400 personnalités de gauche en
désaccord avec la ligne pro nuque du
premier secrétaire du PS Olivier Faure
Mathieu on va vous entendre analyser
cette tribune de Bernard Cazeneuve signe
son retour d'abord plus qu'une tribune
c'est un long manifeste plus une
interview s'il vous plaît donc c'est
vente et services après vente on n'est
jamais mieux servi que par soi-même
fallait au moins ça pour le retour dans
l'arène du plus pince sans rire des
socialistes français alors qu'on se le
dis quand même Bernard Cazeneuve ne
revient pas pourquoi tout simplement
parce qu'il n'était pas parti
explique-t-il et puis ne roule pas pour
lui ne remplit pas un rôle il sert une
cause poursuit-il faut modeste en fait
on a retenu les pics de l'interview la
majorité macroniste et ça fan club la
gauche qui est rétréci à ses franges les
plus sectaires la grande internationale
de la lutte contre le barbecue le PS qui
sait tout ouisé bref on peut voir que
Bernard cazen n'a pas perdu le sens de
la formule qui fait mouche sur le fond
en fait il nous joue un air qui est
assez connu c'est celui de la gauche de
la transformation comme il l'appelle
contre la gauche de la de l'incantation
c'est le vieux débat qui oppose depuis
plus de 100 ans les réformistes contre
les révolutionnaires à gauche le font
pour le coup n'est pas franchement
révolutionnaire même s'il faut noter le
retour d'un mot quand même qui avait
disparu du vocabulaire socialiste je
trouve c'est le progrès qui apparaît
beaucoup dans la Tribune le terme de
progrès la martingale de Bernard
Cazeneuve c'est la suivante en gros des
services publics de qualité pour
permettre une réelle ascension et
justice sociale des valeurs
républicaines réaffirmées notamment la
laïcité on aime l'Union européenne on
fait de la transition écologique mais
avec du nucléaire et puis je lui ai dit
que les corps intermédiaires dans cette
société fracturée tout ça casse pas
trois pattes à un canard mais c'est
plutôt bien fait c'est propre on a
presque envie de dire comme la télé dans
les années 80 merci Bernard mais mais
il y en a plusieurs mais le premier port
sur son rôle Bernard c'est pas n'importe
qui quand même il a été c'est un proche
de François Hollande il a été ministre
de François Hollande pendant 4 ans et
demi pendant 6 mois il a même été son
premier ministre bref il est donc aussi
à sa façon d'une certaine manière
comptable de ces années-là et de la
situation dans laquelle la gauche s'est
retrouvée en 2017 mais de cela j'ai pas
compris s'il y avait le début d'une
analyse auto critique talent pour
l'amnésie chez certains dans le
manifeste le second mai il porte sur
l'instant pourquoi maintenant et pas
plutôt d'une certaine façon parce
qu'après tout Bernard Cazeneuve aurait
pu reprendre le PS comme beaucoup de ses
camarades le lion demandé à l'époque
mais à l'époque c'était sans succès il
ne voulait pas Bernard Cazeneuve aurait
pu se porter candidat à la
présidentielle comme beaucoup de ses
camarades le lui ont demandé à l'époque
mais là encore s'en guerre plus de
succès vous l'avez compris tout le monde
a le droit de changer d'avis et de
choisir son calendrier Bernard Cazeneuve
le fait mais on peut légitimement se
demander si Cazeneuve et sa cavalerie
n'arrive pas à trop tard pour sauver le
Parti socialiste on en profite pour
rappeler les les prochaines échéances
pour les socialistes mais le prochain
congrès d'abord début 2023 qui permettra
aux socialistes de s'adonner à leur
sport favori qui se diviser pour mieux
se compter là il est quand même
intéressant alors on verra ceux qui ont
été exclus ou non parce qu'il ne
soutenaient pas l'accord avec la nuit
pèse vous savez qu'il y a eu des grandes
discussions mais en tout cas ça devrait
permettre en tout cas de de ce compter à
des fautes en shining même si je pense
que Olivier fort sur part quand même
assez favoris dans cette aventure parce
qu'il est quand même auréolé de cet
accord qui a donné des députés et qui a
fait longtemps la voix du PS et après
cette étape il y a une seconde échéance
évidemment qui sont les élections
européennes alors là c'est la première
occasion de voir si les toutous du PS
reprennent leur indépendance ou s'il
reste dans la meute de la lupesse on
verra c'est dans 2 ans et on va rebondir
sur cette analyse Émilie zapaleski c'est
la cavalerie Bernard il arrive il arrive
en retard mais c'est un peu les vieux de
la vieille parce que quand même on est
on est sur un effet vous avez du
ministre de des premiers ministres on
est sur Stéphane Le Foll enfin on est
Cambadélis voilà c'est le PS revisité
moi ce que je trouve intéressant c'est
qu'ils arrivent en effet Carole Delga
qui s'est rajouté aussi et pas Hidalgo
par contre mais Carole Delga oui ça fait
partie peut-être des figures qui peuvent
monter sur la gauche je trouve qu'ils
arrivent après la bataille et d'une
manière un peu opportuniste parce que
finalement quelque part il y a des
thématiques de gauche qui sont
réapparues dans le débat qui ont infusé
dans le débat on le voit même encore la
dernière main avec la conférence
d'Emmanuel Macron même si Bercy Emmanuel
Macron ne veut pas absolument dire taxe
sur les super profits on est quand même
sur une taxe sur les énergéticiens qui
va être distribué je parle au niveau
européen sur les ménages qui a été
annoncé par Emmanuel Macron cet
après-midi alors toute la procédure
européenne qui doit suivre mais en tout
cas c'est dans les tuyaux elles existait
pas je pense que ça vient aussi du fait
que à l'Assemblée nationale il y a des
crieurs qui font partie de la nupette
qui ont un petit peu imposé ces
thématiques Elisabeth borne n'était pas
contre donc il y a ces valeurs qui
refont jour on peut aussi parler Bruno
Le Maire parler du crédit un crédit un
peu recherche vers ça c'était une idée
des écolos plutôt l'isfaire donc on voit
qu'il y a des thématiques qui qui
reprennent à leur qu'on dit c'est pour
ça que moi je suis un peu sceptique on
dit que la France est à droite et là
peut-être que Cazeneuve s'est rendu
compte qu'il y avait une opportunité
pour reparler de ses valeurs de gauche
et qui avait un public qui était preneur
de ça mais oui ils arrivent au bout de
la bataille la nupes malgré tout ce que
tout le monde a dit elle tient on va
voir pour les élections prochaines
européennes mais pour l'instant il sera
bon mais oui mais en attendant
oui à chaque fois on dit elle va se
fracturer ça va pas tenir elle tient
elle fait des propositions ensemble ils
tiennent malgré tout avec des voix
différentes Jean-Luc Mélenchon
d'ailleurs a dit c'est pas grave si on a
des voix différentes du moment qu'on a
un accord minimum puis on avance avec
ceux qui veulent marcher je pense que
c'est tout ça que case neuve a vu il
arrive un peu tard il avait pas envie
bon voilà maintenant il voit
l'opportunité mais moi j'y crois pas j'y
crois pas du tout je pense que ça n'a
pas peur ça peut pas reprendre il y a
trop cette espèce d'ombre qui a fait qui
a Hollande finalement de dépeçage du PS
et il y a plus cette ligne que
représente d'une manière beaucoup plus
extrême la nupaisse
et parce que il était largement commenté
mais ça m'intéresse de savoir ce que
vous en pensez mais un mot de la
popularité de Bernard Cazeneuve mais
évidemment vous l'avez testé notamment
avant la présidentielle il est populaire
mais pas suffisamment pour se lancer
dans une présidentielle c'est c'est quoi
la l'analyse en fait sur le papier il
pourrait être suffisamment populaire
pour pouvoir se présenter à l'élection
présidentielle sur le papier c'était là
qu'il y a quand même une grande
différence entre la popularité et le
comportement électoral aujourd'hui il y
a une image qui est une image d'homme
droit de personnes qui d'ailleurs a su
tenir pendant la période des attentats
qui a la République cheville au corps et
qui globalement donne le sentiment
d'avoir un cortex qui est assez fort et
qui est pas toujours présent en fait de
la part des personnes qui sont
issues du Parti socialiste et pour
autant dès lors qu'on teste d'un point
de vue général au terme d'intention de
vote ou en termes de parcours politique
qui pourrait jouer à l'avenir c'est
confiance ou cette opinion extrêmement
poétique a tendance à se dilapider de
manière extrêmement rapide expliqué les
le côté j'y vais j'y vais pas
ça explique ou c'est la cause
une des raisons explicatives à nos yeux
c'est-à-dire que jusqu'à présent il y a
un peu la perception en fait de la part
des électeurs que
Bernard Cazeneuve a envie d'être
président mais n'a pas toujours envie de
faire campagne il a envie d'exercer des
responsabilités mais il a pas envie de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour pouvoir aller
chercher ses responsabilités il y a un
regard très ambivalent de la part de nos
compatriotes c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
extrêmement critiques et les gars des
responsa positif ou on leur dit vous
voulez toujours le pouvoir vous faites
tout pouvoir y arriver etc mais dans un
même élan quand ils le font pas ils
bénéficient pas d'un support d'un point
de vue d'opinion et jusqu'à présent il y
a pas vraiment une campagne c'est à dire
qu'il y a pas eu d'actions qui ont été
menées de la part de Bernard Cazeneuve
il y a pas eu de tourner des fédérations
il y a pas eu en fait de d'expression de
sa part en disant je souhaiterais être
candidat à l'élection présidentielle il
y a pas eu même de mobilisation de
troupeau et donc dans ce contexte là
c'est plus en fait une forme de figure
tutélaire qui existe et qui ne permet
pas aujourd'hui de se transformer en
termes de regard extrêmement positif sur
un registre qui est extrêmement
différent c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé pour Christiane Taubira qui était
extrêmement forte d'un point de vue
d'opinion qui disposait d'un capital de
d'appréciation de la part des électeurs
de gauche d'un point de vue général qui
était extrêmement élevé mais dès lors
qu'on l'a testé en termes d'intention de
vote dans le cadre de l'élection
présidentielle et je dis ça avant
qu'elle n'ait pas plus présentée elle
était très basse donc il y avait cette
forme de différence entre une forme de
capacité à pouvoir donner des lignes de
conduite qui sont appréciables mais qui
sont pas forcément en capacité pour être
porté par l'émetteur à proprement parler
alors le PS tout utilisé par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon on écoute la réponse d'Olivier
fort c'est le premier secrétaire du PS
évidemment c'était sur France Inter hier
un certain temps que ce qui m'intéresse
ce ne sont plus réalistes qui sont
contre tout le monde enfin qui a une
espèce de gauche qui n'aime pas la
gauche qui n'aime pas les écologistes
qui n'aiment pas les communistes qui
avaient signé cette tribune en fait je
vois qu'il y a des gens qui sont des
soutiens de longue date de d'Emmanuel
Macron qui soutiennent son action au
gouvernement je vois des gens qui
bizarrement on demandait aussi être
soutenu par la nuque pour leur élections
législatives et qui maintenant sont je
peux donner le nom et le pas là pour
faire les mêmes droping mais il y a des
gens qui vous verrez vous regarderez des
gens qui n'ont pas eu de concurrents à
gauche pour leur élections et qui
maintenant vient de dire les insoumis
les écologistes Jean garrigue cette
expression Olivier Faure toutou de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou le PS toutouisé
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez alors
d'abord je pense qu'il est pas très
honnête de la part d'Olivier fort de
renvoyer les 400 signataires de ce de ce
manifeste et notamment Bernard Cazeneuve
un soutien plus ou moins déguisé à
Emmanuel Macron ou au contraire un
mécanisme par rapport à la nupes parce
que Bernard Cazeneuve il y a beaucoup de
défauts mais au moins on peut lui
reconnaître celui d'une certaine rigueur
ça lui a été reproché d'ailleurs mais
pour ne pas lui son argument pour
expliquer une forme de mise en retrait
c'est de dire que justement il ne
voulait pas perturber ce qu'était les
campagnes successives de du Parti
socialiste et on ne peut pas lui
reprocher d'avoir été à la soupe auprès
de Macron ça c'est un fait important
deuxièmement si vous comparez en termes
de statut par rapport à l'opinion
publique en termes de stature d'hommes
d'État Bernard Cazeneuve et Olivier fort
je pense que la différence elle est elle
est immédiate pour la plupart des
Français maintenant la question de la
totorisation elle est fondamentale parce
que c'est la question de l'avenir de la
gauche je veux dire que on s'est bien
qu'elle a été la trajectoire de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avec Mélenchon est parti de du
Parti socialiste parce qu'il était en
désaccord avec la ligne et surtout parce
qu'il était minoritaire et parce qu'il
était parce qu'il voulait il a décidé à
un moment donné
[Musique]
exactement et je sais tout simplement
l'explication de de la démarche d'un
Cazeneuve je pense Cazeneuve pense que
c'est une autre gauche qui peut faire
gagner les gauches donc est-ce que
est-ce que c'est encore un calcul qui
est applicable en 2022 ça c'est encore
autre chose et encore plus en 2027 mais
de toute manière on voit bien que là il
y a quelque chose qui se joue dans la
reconstruction de la gauche or moi
j'estime que au cas où probable il y ait
une sorte de dislocation de la macronie
dans les cinq ans qui viennent c'est
inévitable il va y avoir un potentiel il
va y avoir un espace politique justement
pour cette gauche pour ces républer
républicains de gauche que représente
Bernard cazen et donc je suis pas du
tout sûr que son initiative aujourd'hui
soit condamnée à l'échec c'est une
possibilité mais si vous voulez sur le
plan politique à long terme il y a
éventuellement un espace pour lui
Matthieu il va venir détestation que les
uns et les autres se voient entre
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ses anciens
camarades du PS il y a chez certains en
PS c'est qui est exactement ce que
disent les gens c'est vrai qu'ils ne
pensent pas qu'il y ait de majorité
sociologique majorité et la doctorale en
France pour une offre de gauche radicale
on se retrouve on disait révolutionnaire
parce que ces gens-là qui sont pas des
thurifères forcément de François
Hollande disent on sait bien que en
France vu la pyramide des âges vue l'âge
des votants le penchant pour la
radicalité et minoritaire il y aura pas
50% plus un des Français qui voteront
forcément vers vous j'en ai pour
répondre à cette question
jusqu'à présent de l'histoire jusqu'à
présent c'est le sens de l'histoire
après ce qui est intéressant c'est que
il y a une différence entre le propos
qui peut être tenu et la personnalité
qui le tient c'est-à-dire que quand vous
testez aujourd'hui un somme d'argument
qui sont exprimés de la part de la
France insoumise sans dire aux personnes
interrogées que ça provient de la France
et sans même utiliser le terme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon globalement il y a un soutien
qui est un soutien qui n'est pas
majoritaire mais qui est même
trois ans écrasant que vous ça rejoint
ce que disait Émilie sur la France
à une forme de justice sociale qui
traverse globalement notre pays
quasiment depuis 1789 si vous ajoutez un
terme à côté de cela à quel terme
français insoumise ou si vous ajoutez un
deuxième terme qui est un terme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon là pour le coup et ben le
regard est un regard beaucoup plus
distant parce qu'en fait il y a pas
uniquement le fond il y a également la
forme la manière dont les idées sont
exposées et leur effet politique qui
peut être perçu de la part des citoyens
parce que ça n'apparaît pas toujours
comme étant par la suite une adjonction
de mesure mais un système politique et
là ce système politique va également
interroger d'un point de vue plus
générale alors on sait que du côté de la
France insoumise il théorise le fait que
de toute façon il faut parler fort parce
qu'il dit autrement on se fait jamais
entendre voilà donc ils sont justement
pris dans cette forme des taux en se
disant qu'ils sont obligés s'ils veulent
se faire entendre passer le mur du son
médiatique entre guillemets arriver à
créer justement ces lignes de fracture
d'un point de vue d'opinion et dans un
même mélange qui pas toujours rejetée
dans l'absolu en tout cas mesure par
mesure et alors ça explique aussi la
stratégie de ce parti d'opposition mais
ce n'est pas le seul face au Conseil
national de la refondation je pense que
Steve Jourdain doit être juste là Steve
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
la saison 2 de sens public vous serez la
régulièrement évidemment comme d'autres
brillants journalistes de la rédaction
de de Public Sénat alors on fait un peu
de pédagogie vous nous rappeler ce
qu'est ce CNR le CNR c'est une nouvelle
méthode de gouvernement en tout cas
comme ça qu'Emmanuel Macron a présenté
les choses petit retour en arrière
Thomas on est début juin juste avant les
élections législatives Emmanuel Macron
accorde alors une interview à la presse
régionale et il annonce un changement de
méthode pour son second quinquennat
manière de répondre à ceux qui
l'accusent de pratiquer un pouvoir trop
solitaire trop vertical trop jupitérien
il déclare la chose suivante j'ai porté
cinq objectifs pendant la campagne
électorale l'indépendance le plein
emploi neutralité carbone les services
publics pour l'égalité des chances et la
Renaissance démocratique avec la réforme
institutionnelle pour les atteindre je
veux réunir un conseil national de la
refondation avec les forces politiques
économiques sociales associatives des
élus des territoires et de citoyens
tirés au sort il faut rassembler la
nation autour de ces priorités fin de
citation on le voit le CNR c'est à
l'origine quelque chose de très
ambitieux c'est pas vraiment étonnant on
est juste avant les élections
législatives et Emmanuel Macron pense
obtenir une majorité plutôt confortable
à l'Assemblée nationale on sait comment
ça s'est terminé pour lui effectivement
ça c'est donc début juin qu'est-ce qu'on
sait depuis est-ce qu'on a plus de
détails sur les contours de ce conseil
national leur fondation non non pour le
moment tout est flou la seule chose qui
est sûre c'est que ça sera François
Bayrou qui présidera les débats on nous
dit aussi qu'Emmanuel Macron pourrait
soumettre certaines propositions du CNR
en référendum et puis c'est à peu près
tout Thomas c'est à peu près tout ce
qu'on sait du Conseil national de la
chronique
c'est tellement flou concernant même de
la majorité présidentielle certains d'où
de son utilité ce matin il y a le droit
de Pivet président de l'Assemblée
nationale a essayé de remobiliser les
troupes écouter là le Parlement siège et
siège en ce moment même le Parlement ça
n'est pas que la séance publique dans
l'hémicycle je pourrais habitude de dire
l'hémicycle c'est la partie émergée de
l'iceberg
évidemment la question avant jeudi c'est
qui va y participer pas Gérard lâcher
pas le président du Sénat regardez cette
lettre qu'il a envoyé Emmanuel Macron
c'était fin août le risque de confusion
que le Conseil national de la
refondation recèle et les incertitudes
qui demeurent sur son rôle véritable et
perçu comme une forme de contournement
du Parlement c'est-à-dire de la
représentation nationale pas le Gérard
Larcher donc pas de Sénat ou CNR ce
jeudi même son cloche du côté des
oppositions RN elle est en UPS tous
dénonce une opération comme de la part
du chef de l'État je vous ai fait une
petite liste de ceux qui en seront et de
ceux qui n'en seront pas c'est non pour
les principales associations des liloko
associations des maires de France
assemblés des départements de France
région de France c'est donc non
également pour les républicains le RN la
nups et le syndicat solidaire en
revanche c'est oui pour la République en
marche évidemment le modèle la CFDT la
CFE-CGC la CPME ou encore le Medef on
attend maintenant la position la réponse
définitive de la CGT et de Force
ouvrière mais a priori pour les deux
centrales syndicales ce sera non ce sera
niet pour elle aussi le CNR pour
l'instant une institution très très
confidentielle merci Steve pour cette
analyse est-ce qu'il est mort nez ce CNR
Jean Gary c'est toujours difficile de le
dire il parait assez mal le Conseil
National de la Résistance à l'époque il
avait deux avantages c'est que il était
porté par le général de Gaulle dans le
prestige historique était incontournable
c'est pas le cas d'Emmanuel Macron et
puis il pouvait s'appuyer sur l'ensemble
des partis politiques de la droite à la
gauche et des syndicats qui qui étaient
représentés plus les mouvements de
résistance donc là on est évidemment
dans un cas de figure totalement
différent avec ce conseil national de de
la refondation c'est vrai qu'on n'en
sait pas grand chose mais c'est vrai
aussi que au moment où on assiste quand
même une résurgence du parlementarisme
dont je me suis félicité abondamment
donc moi je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs
notamment sur ce plateau notamment sur
ce plateau
on assiste à une résurgence du Parlement
ça a été le Sénat au départ et qu'à
faire Benalla et cetera c'est le c'est
aujourd'hui l'Assemblée nationale il y a
un C2 c'est économique social
environnemental on se demande
véritablement ce que peut être le le
l'espace d'évolu à ce à ce à cette
nouvelle Assemblée maintenant dans
l'absolu moi je suis pas con parce que
on a assez reproché à Emmanuel Macron sa
président jupiterienne le fait de créer
quelque chose une instance de
concertation préliminaire au débat
parlementaire mais l'instance de
concertation qui soit pas simplement de
la concertation qui soit ensuite une
instance de proposition y compris
d'amendement de ce que pourrait être la
ligne
proposée par le Président de la
République externe une instance dans
laquelle on pourrait véritablement
transformer ce que ce qu'est le
chronomètre je sais bien que là je suis
dans une
utopie totale mais ça dans l'absolu ça
pourrait être très intéressant je vous
demande d'être bref les uns et les
autres parce que
le temps a filé un mot là dessus d'avant
grand débat national convention
citoyenne sur le climat le résultat de
décision ça a été zéro donc c'est encore
une concertation pour blablater moi ce
que je trouve assez
comique c'est que c'est vrai que ça
ressemble un peu à ses œufs un Conseil
économique social et environnemental bis
c'est François Bayrou qui devrait
prendre la tête du Conseil national et
le CESU a retoqué un petit peu la
première note que Bayrou avait fait sur
le quand il est au commissaire aux plans
quoi donc il se fait retoquer sur
l'écologie sur la pauvreté et là on nous
remet ça avec François Bayrou à la tête
je trouve qu'on prend beaucoup de temps
pour les diagnostics qu'on connaît déjà
il faudrait peut-être des décisions je
pense que c'était pas le lieu forcément
d'un diagnostic moi je pense qu'on peut
pas dire on peut pas dire en France il y
a une crise de la représentation
démocratique on a des taux d'obtention
record on a une société fracturée
qui a un discours qu'un constat que font
à peu près toutes les forces politiques
et jeter toute initiative de d'essayer
de faire un peu autrement alors bien sûr
Emmanuel Macron est derrière pensé bien
sûr il espère embarquer tout le monde
dans un calendrier de réforme et bien
sûr son passé ne peut pas pour lui parce
qu'il est une présence très verticale
après il a pas des choses élector la
Suisse puisque a priori il pourra pas se
représenter ça c'est une chose mais de
la part des oppositions eux aussi ont
des arrières pensées c'est que les gens
ne veulent pas y aller pourquoi mais
pour essayer de faire chuter Macron de
pas faire un cadeau à l'exécutif allez
et donc les mêmes qui se targuent le mot
sur il faudrait concilier la France il
faut pouvoir élaborer ensemble il faut
rechercher du consensus aucun de vue de
consensus tout le monde est en césarien
mais d'ailleurs c'est intéressant parce
que je dis qu'est-ce qui va se passer à
Marcoussis vers une sorte de de comptage
parce qu'a fait Steve dans sa chronique
à l'instant bon bah il y a le constat de
la des chaises vides vous voyez ce que
je veux dire j'en ai une vie et ça je
pense moi que dans l'opinion ça ça
finira par peser parce que c'est
peut-être de la corne c'est peut-être
vide de sens mais le gouvernement
l'exécutif tend la main aux opposition
au Parlement là au CNR pour l'instant
sans avoir de réponse encore une fois je
suis pas je suis pas dupe de du
caractère de comme de cette main tendue
mais comment ça pèse dans l'opinion ça
les refus successifs là pour l'instant
en fait personne ne sait exactement ce
qu'elle CNR et je pense que nous quatre
au taux la table on n'est pas forcément
d'accord sur à quoi il va servir donc
enfin plus l'objet sera défini plus en
fait les Français pourront se
positionner par rapport à celui-ci parce
qu'en fait genre indiqué en fait que
c'était probablement une instance de
concertation préalable à la mobilisation
en fait des corps législatifs constitués
ça a pas forcément été indiqué de cette
manière là et même voilà et donc et donc
même le fait que du côté d'en marche ou
du côté des ministres à travers des
indiscrets plus ou moins discrets et ils
disent en gros on y croit pas on n'est
pas d'accord on est on a du mal à savoir
ce que c'est ça ça rend les choses
difficiles donc peut-être que déjà le
premier aspect ça sera définir l'objet
définir la temporalité peut-être définir
une méthode de travail un objectif
précis puis après voir justement si les
Français sont plus ou moins sévères avec
ceux qui vont adopter la politique de la
chaise vide merci beaucoup merci à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce premier
débat de la saison 2 de sciences
publiques on était j'espère au niveau de
la saison 1 donc je veux pas trop la
ramener c'est sur les téléspectateurs
qui jugeront en tout cas c'était un
plaisir de redémarrer avec cette actu
politique et avec vous quatre